Julie Chen says that you behaved very
badly in restaurants that you're that
you love to do outrageous things in
restaurants such as what what have you
done in restaurants that's so outrageous
I don't know why this is but I
definitely have done a few bad nights
with Julie and her husband who is you
know les Moonves and you know much
respect to him and and everybody at CBS
but it just seems that every time they
see me in the evening I'm out of my mind
right and I do really naughty bad things
like tell me an example of what you've
done that's so naughty and dad in
restaurant well I like slack people's
heads and pull the hair at different
tables people you know or nobody I know
no don't be stupid no stranger no one I
know what do you do and and what do you
you're slapping their heads you're
pushing their what are you doing push
the head into the dinner and that's what
you get arrested for but I go like oh
when I drink too much and then Oh fine
well that's okay sometimes I like
exposed my breasts you'll expose your
breasts
[Applause]
not drunk can't do it yeah one time
where is this restaurant out there he
was waiting for me to arrive at the
restaurant and I was than the other
girls were there at the table and it was
near the window so I got my breath out
and squashed them against the window
good lord so people walking by on the
street saw who know is really people in
the restaurant see you're outside so
people in the restaurant we're eating
their food and then there's your breasts
right they're squashed up fantastic so
why now I now have made it a rule I will
never drink with Julie again as socially
because it's not fair it's right right
right I think you should kick it up yeah
my job if you haven't lost your job yet
you're not gonna lose your job doing
that right you've already figured out
when you're around the network president
take your top off yeah yeah thank God he
was should take the breasts out and hit
people in the head
[Applause]
or just get them in somebody's food yes
tea with summer 13 oh that's hot don't
do that
I'll screw that for you
a cream on your coat
you'll regret all of it hey thanks for
watching please subscribe to my youtube
channel
so they will stop making me shoot these
videos please